I think it's also really important for
guys to understand that you know a woman
has to earn that right with you yeah
yeah what level of investment is she
putting in and I think it's always a
really interesting conversation where
you know how you treat a girl that
you're seeing is how she's going to
perceive herself so if you're doing
boyfriend girlfriend stuff if you're
going on trips if you're taking
vacations if you're doing all kind of
that you know she's going to sort of
assume that that's where things are and
a lot of guys have a problem with
speaking of over investment this is
something I've had two guys come to me
recently about
um is just
over investment too much too early as
far as texting goes you know that's a
big one that a lot of guys mess up to
get the match they get the number
they're texting maybe they can't meet up
for like a week week and a half and
they're just texting every day the good
morning text good night text all that
kind of [ __ ] but
I've always said that how you start a
relationship with a woman is how she's
going to expect it to stay or go up
there's no ramping down it's either
going to be the same level of investment
from the jumper it's going to go up so
if you're texting every day and you're
constantly of this and maybe you get
bored after a while because you've gone
out with her a couple of times and now
things are kind of stale you maybe ramp
down the texting a little bit she's
gonna notice she's gonna freak out
what's going on what are we where are we
stand what's happening you're not
talking as much like why aren't you
hitting me up it's always always better
and easier to ramp up than it ever is to
start off you know because you have to
live up to that so the guys that are
throwing money around or saying hey on
our first date we're gonna do this
extravagant stuff or we're gonna go on a
vacation on our third date or something
like that or spend a weekend wherever
you know that's that's the it's kind of
funny because it's like in divorce you
know she's grown accustomed to a
lifestyle that she has now come to
expect from you and then when that stops
you know that's that's normal how you
meet her is normal uh let me just talk
about like that investment component of
it because it's like that's that's
really really important I'm glad that
you brought that up
um like the whole of her earning your
time or more of your time or a
dedication of your time whether it's
solely or if it's shared doesn't matter
but the whole you know component of her
earning it a lot of guys Overlook that
it's like they'll be like oh you know
she touched my pee pee so she's earned
it now so
uh did you get sick did she look after
you
um can you hand her a dry cleaning
receipt and say you know pick this up
for me when you're out today uh I'm on a
business for a meeting for the next four
hours so when you come over on this day
of the week do me a solid you know can
you pick up dinner and make it for us
you know sort of thing like has she
earned it right has she invested into
the relationship because women fall in
love with men when they're doing things
for them it's not the other way around
right like a lot of guys think oh if I
take her out to a nice restaurant then
she's gonna fall in love with me it's
like
she's gonna eat nicely she's going to
get a great pick for Instagram stories
but did she really fall in love with you
like did she
another thing too is I always go back to
the availability standpoint so normally
I'm pretty busy I don't rearrange my
schedule to accommodate women I leave
blocks in my schedule to where maybe
their miscellaneous blocks or creative
blocks or whatever and then a woman
could potentially fall into that so
usually at 8 pm I'll play I'll play
guitar for an hour and then I'll cook
dinner I'll eat I'll unwind and I'll go
to bed so usually 8 P.M onward I'm open
for women to come over we I still do the
same activities I'll just have a plus
one
um and I've noticed that really women
will kind of pick what place they're at
in your life and a lot of guys don't
know this too I've said on this channel
before people always flip out in the
comments but they're just not living in
reality women have rosters too they have
multiple options that doesn't mean she's
sleeping with every guy on the roster
but she has she has her she has her
lineup she has guys she can go to for
certain things you need to make sure
that you're the guy that hey if I'm
gonna hang out with Jaren like we are
going to be intimate because that sets
you aside uh from the other guys and you
make it very clear the type of
relationship you have with her it is a
physical relationship ship and so I'll
notice that I'll tell girls hey come
over at 8pm on a Friday or whatever I'm
gonna have a chill night and then if
they show up that's fantastic I'll take
a mental note of that that she
enthusiastically showed up she didn't
flake or cancel or push the date back
and then she was good company there and
then she will have more opportunity to
fill that hole in my schedule so I can
then fill her a hole and then when they
don't I like to do the fun so I'm trying
to I'm trying to get get nerdy on here
uh and when they don't you just have to
make a mental checkpoint it might not be
anything with you uh guys in the uh
private signal group I think I sent a a
busty Venezuelan chick a couple months
ago I was like all right this girl you
know seems pretty cool she might be the
running for for my new main chick I'm
actually I have that slot open
um and uh in the last couple weekends oh
I'm gonna come to town and then okay
Friday to Sunday and I left the weekend
open and planned a bunch of cool stuff
that I think we'd both enjoy and she
fights two weekends in a row so I just
sent her my standard hey let me know
when you're already in town in your are
actually free in the moment and if I
happen to also be free you can come over
we can see each other real quick guys
that know anything about girls they know
exactly what that means and I've demoted
her from potential mltr category to just
just any other girl you know um and she
did she did that to herself so guys uh
on my channel always say you always need
to keep in mind or be mindful of her
level of attraction towards you and that
that often surfaces in terms of her
availability so I want to ask Jaren this
question because this recently came up
to with with a buddy of mine where you
know standard you hear about the stuff
all the time this was the same guy that
was kind of having a problem with over
investment and over texting they'd hung
out they were spending a lot of time
together uh she goes so she goes cold
over an entire week and he texts he
calls nothing couple of days go by I
think they had plans something like that
and she just bail uh I don't know if she
stood him up or just failed or whatever
but you know a couple days later she
comes back oh my God I'm so sorry my mom
was in town I just was so busy and uh
you know so I was kind of giving him
like Hey like you need to demote this
chick like she's not she's she needs to
kind of earn this back but you know is
there any coming back from that like is
there any coming back from Once once
she's and maybe it depends on the on the
you know the uh aggression and the
boundary that she crossed but
um you know it's like look if you if you
run into that or she cancels a date or
she does something like that you know at
what point and how how much you have are
you putting her through the ringer
before you're like all right like you
you're gonna get another shot
that is a really good question I think
obviously she'll be demoted a bit she'll
have to go step back and I actually had
this happen once in San Diego I was
dating a new girl she was really really
into me uh at this point I was just kind
of new to these types of topics so I
made her like officially my my
girlfriend and within a month she
screwed it up I caught her already
texting ex-boyfriends uh we went to a
bar one night like granted we we both uh
we split uh we split a tab of ecstasy
with a European couple we met and uh it
was pretty fun but at one point I went
to the bathroom and I came out and she
was like dancing she was grinding on
some guy and he was like kissing on her
neck and I just walked past her and left
the club and just left her there and I
could see the look on her face it was
absolute Terror it's like oh my God and
she knew she screwed up and she
eventually came home uh had her stuff
outside um I was gonna make her sleep
outside but eventually I let her sleep
on the floor hit the foot of my bed and
um and then the next morning she was
from Tijuana I was in San Diego at the
time next morning I sent her home and I
told her like hey you're like you
clearly know we're done and um she was
blowing me oh give me a chance give me a
chance in my head I just mentally delete
those people I don't have time for that
but
um and I I did the same thing that I did
with this recently this Venezuelan girl
I was like okay well clearly and my
friends and I would joke about this this
is seriously the bucket I put them in at
the time um I said hey clearly you're
not girlfriend material like we made
that very clear but um I am willing to
put you uh you know when you watch a
movie and they always have like stunt
man number one or like random guy at
coffee shop number two uh so I told her
was like I was like I'll create a new
category in my dating life you can be
[ __ ] number one so like you'll never be
my Main Chick you'll never be a
girlfriend you made it very clear that
you're incapable of doing that but you
can be horror number one so like of all
like the random chicks I'm betting uh if
there's a conflict that comes up I will
give you priorities like but that's
that's the last slot you get in my life
don't screw it up and from that point
forward that was like seven years ago
um she's coming here in a couple weeks
she has been just 100 just on point with
me um I don't expect her to be
monogamous because I'm not in San Diego
anymore but she understands the don't
Poison the Well concept I've never had
any issues with her and when she when
she comes down she rubs my feet my back
and cooks and cleans and she helps me
with a lot of my creative stuff guys
that collaborate with me my professional
life or creative Endeavors they've
probably met her before
um but when it comes time to get on an
airplane or go out and meet new people
in town she's not in that position so my
main girl represents me and my
girlfriend I don't have that category
open anymore in my life the girlfriend's
pretty much the the main girl in the
mltr equation hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipment will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out